mucho are you serve how are you compadre
I'm good I am doing well so what what's
going through Mike McCarthy's mind right
now right now there's no question in his
mind that Aaron Rodgers is done for the
season correct I don't know you he said
he got hit 12 times which is more than
he's been hit since the middle of the
fifth of 2015 season and when you get
hit the most with 13 screws in your
shoulder passing clavicle that's cause
for concern I guess when you're not in
the playoffs anymore so it's gonna be
interesting to see did they say anything
today no no and that's my point is that
there's no question
so I guess walked me through it's a no
brainer I mean there's no reason what so
you could break his clavicle again for
for a game that means absolutely nothing
well you know and Brett Brett Hundley
could use the actual reps and and in all
honesty the Packers could use a couple
of losses on their schedule if that's
possible to get a better draft pick
there's no reason to put him out there
shame on you are you talking about the
Packers tanking the season ok so here's
here's it this is an analogy but it's
not a good one so the New York giant
right set up playoffs too and Eli
continues to play he came off you know
he came off the bench to start a new
consecutive streak to continue to play
now the difference is he doesn't have a
bunch of plays and plates and screws in
his shoulders that's the difference so
there's a there's probably a bit of a
back-and-forth I don't know I don't want
to call it a conflict but common sense I
guess tells you that hey Aaron you know
thank you for trying to get ready to
play again you were you were brave and
you gave it your all and right now we're
out of it so there's no purpose and you
plain right now you don't need to prove
anything nor need to risk that shoulder
get healthy for next year and the five
years after that we have a lot of
reasons to play Huntley and and finish
up the best way we can give him some
experience and we're going to save you
and not put you out there to risk it
anymore that makes all the sense in the
world then there's the other hand
that says err Roger says you know what I
came I I rehab my butt off as best I
could to get back with my teammates that
I've been leading for a decade now and I
want to finish the season with them
because I'm cleared to play and I feel
well enough to play and this is my job
and I and I want to do my job the best
way I can so there's there's a little
bit of that too I'm sure
Aaron Rodgers is such a competitor if he
feels well enough to play if he didn't
get a setback and I don't know if he's
going to practice this week or not rich
you know who knows but that and it
doesn't get any easier there's the
Vikings that's a team that hurt them in
the first place boy oh boy it's it's a
it's a tough one you would think it's a
no-brainer you know and it should be
like a rest but there's a certain
element of a competitiveness in teams
and in players that want to allow you
know people to do what they do and Aaron
Rodgers he makes a living playing
football and he likes to do that Steve
Mariucci here on the Rich Eisen show who
was the biggest red ass that didn't want
to be taken out of a game that you had
to take out of a game in your coaching
career
well I took I told you the story
remember that in the office when I would
pull Steve Young out at the end of again
at the end of a game because he got the
concussion the first game of the season
when I was coaching him Jerry Rice blows
the knee out Steve Young gets a
concussion and then we lose our opener
to Tampa sap sappy 45 years old today
anyway so from then on I said you know
you're coming out you're coming out once
you start playing again at the a if we
have a lead you're coming out well he
hated that because he wanted to finish
every game like Peyton Manning did like
Favre did like guys do you play this is
my team I'm finishing the game I'm gonna
take a knee if we need to I'll take a
knee but I'm playing anyway so as I
don't know we're at home 31 to 7 winning
and I I told my coaches go tell Steve
he's coming out and they both went
Napper and Marty morning I ain't telling
him you tell him I tell him he doesn't
want to come out so I had to go chase
him around and I found him he was hiding
from me
behind the kickers net and I found him
and I said Steve you're coming out and
he gave me that cross sign with his
fingers no
like I was a vampire and so you know
that these guys don't want to come out
they want to play you prepare all your
life in all ways and all season
offseason to play these games and they
want to finish them Steve Mariucci here
on the show I found him behind the
kickers net I never had to do that
before find your quarterback behind the
kickers man all places he could have hid
behind that like the Gatorade to hide
probably never played hide-and-go-seek
when he was a kid I don't know is the
real bad way sighs oh my gosh
so did did foals prove anything to you
or that I I mean that that was a weird
game I mean the defense suddenly
disappeared this week they've got 12
wins and and they've got the path that
that right right to the Super Bowl going
through Philadelphia all they have to do
is just win win one more time and they
and they get that what did you take out
of that Eagles near-miss against the
Giants you know the Giants defense that
was a little worried for Nick Foles
before this game because if the Giants
defense plays like it can like they paid
him to play you know they paid him a
couple hundred million dollars of new
money last year and in to add some good
players they have some good players a
couple injuries but you know this is I
said oh boy if this Giants defense plays
like it can it might be a rough day for
Nick Foles well he threw four touchdown
passes any no interceptions he took care
of the ball he looked like he functioned
in this offense well and you know so I I
gave him a two thumbs up if that's not
easy you know even though it's a team
the Giants who are you know - and there
were 2 and 11 going in this game is
still was a pretty good defense so I'm
confident in Nick Foles now he's had
these good years before over in Philly
in 13 when he took over for Michael Vick
he started 10 games he went eight and
two at the back up but now he's more
experienced than that and it's a
quarterback friendly system form I think
he's going to be fine the two top teams
in the NFC both have backup quarterbacks
Case Keenum and Nick Foles but you know
what they're the two favorites still
so who's the best team right now Steve
32 games to go who is the best team I
give you a total mulligan right now on
your Super Bowl who is your Super Bowl
preseason pick again yeah but we had a
mulligan remember huh no I know I'm
Thanksgiving I'm just when I walk
through here I picked the Patriots over
the Packers okay
and they may be sure you took them and
then we changed it I took the Packers
out and I said it was going to be the
rematch of the Andy Reid tío writable
agents over the Eagles right and it
still might be that but you know what
yeah I'm laboring I'm wavering a little
bit because the Vike I really like the
Vikings
I really like the Rams but did you see
that ovation when when Teddy Bridgewater
came into the game at the Vikings now
and the fans went crazy Case Keenum was
his biggest fan it was spectacular I'm
going this this city is going to go
bonkers bonkers if they get this team
back to the Superbowl so don't count the
Vikings out either they look like
they've got the right chemistry on that
team along with the Eagles and then and
I think about those Rams it's entirely
possible Steve that if that that that
this could be their last road game of
the year coming up on Saturday against
Green Bay that Saturday night game that
we discussed to start our conversation
here and the same way that the Patriots
go home for their last two it looks like
they might not have to get on a plane
until the the last week of January it
really is remarkable how that's all
turned out
did you see before I let you go did you
see the news that Eddie DeBartolo might
be thinking of getting back into
ownership based on what's going on in
Carolina did you see that Steve no I
didn't see it but it doesn't surprise me
in the least they're there have there
have been some flirtations with mr.
DeBartolo and his group with some other
openings or you know teams that may or
may not be for sale you hear rumors all
the time the league in my humble opinion
the league misses him he's a he's a
great owner he he would be good for the
league I don't know if Carolina's what
he wants I don't know I haven't spoken
to him about it I will
but but it wouldn't surprise me at all
he would be terrific mm-hmm and I have
to ask you to tell one more story Steve
based on what we what we did on game day
morning last week where it was the
animal it was the anniversary of the
Jerry Rice day
well we're tre I thought you were gonna
go the other no no okay Jerry right
that's like Fight Club we won't talk
about that but it was the anniversary of
Jerry Rice Day in San Francisco where
Terrell Owens on that day God cut
twenty-two targets and caught a
record-breaking twenty catches breaking
the record of Jerry Rice what listening
to this show right now what was that
right I tell it truthfully he's gonna
call me and goes mooch what are you
doing you said it on the air you told
her on NFL Network no he was past rich I
mean he goes well I had it planned we
had this big celebration planned I mean
it was we were gonna we were going we
had a stage a stage like there's going
to be a concert in at half-court after
the game so he can thank the fans and
say I love you and it's been great like
Joe DiMaggio okay I mean there was a big
production after the game planned okay
so I figured okay this is last one he's
going to be gone he's been great I'm
gonna pull him out like the basketball
team's do and then they get the standing
ovation right that's only appropriate in
my mind well I did that in the fourth
quarter and he came off and we're
shutting out the Cowboys I'm sorry the
Bears the Bears and he bends over and he
gave me a mouthful man I thought this
was supposed to be my day mooch what i
hack and please please bleep and and and
the only had like three or four catches
Pio had 20 catches he was so mad that
you know it just kind of went that way
trust me we tried to get him the ball
but dick Durant's not an idiot he
doubled him the whole game right we
couldn't get him the ball so the so the
ball went to tio when you work through
your progression and he was just yelling
and he was going I'm not doing that
speech you can shove it you know this
so I go oh geez fine go back in so he
goes it comes back in we throw a sprint
right option he gets mangled because it
was covered - cuz I got one yard gain in
a bruise that's what it was
so anyway we ended up punting and the
fans are still cheering Jerry Jerry I'm
going oh my god we're winning in a
shutout and we should be taking a knee
so I said heck with it I'm taking a knee
so next time we got the ball Jeff Garcia
goes down takes a knee
the fans hit louder Jerry Jerry and he's
going I'm not doing that speech I said I
am not doing it so I go fine go back in
there we throw him a post we throw him a
post and he caught it for a 24 yard gate
and now the fans are really going crazy
this is when we're supposed to be taking
indeed running out the clock against my
good friend Victor on I was pathetic
and then I said that's it I'm not doing
anymore there's your catch take a knee
Jeff let's get out of here and and
finally I ended the game and dick Geron
came across the field and I was done up
I did apologize he goes mooch I get it
don't worry about it I get it and then
Jerry did the speech he did the speech
so I did the kneel down post pattern
kneel down things just to make Jerry do
the speech and he was very eloquent and
it carried him off and the rest is
history
and then you does it against me and then
you went into the locker room
love you mucho see ever maybe the
greatest player ever to play the game
love him to death
he's the best love you mood should take
care all right you guys it's Steve
Mariucci the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience